au québec maintenant rejoint pierre
fatigué bonne ministre de l'économie de
l'innovation bonsoir monsieur fait given
bon sens du détail on le programme un
peu que vous avez présenté aujourd'hui 2
milliards 500 millions en prêts
garanties de prêts pourquoi vous
fonctionné comme ça que quelle est la
démarche derrière le choix d'offrir des
prêts et des garanties de prêts
premièrement je pense que le plus
important c'est l'efficience du système
il faut être rapide pour réagir on sait
très bien que nos pme ont déjà une crise
est présentement je suis très satisfait
de voir que les banques jacques team ce
corps dit tantôt après monsieur vachon
et les autres dirigeants bancaires
québécois je pense les ventes font un
travail extraordinaire pour alléger le
fardeau des entreprises en nous la
solution préférée c'est que nous nos
clients notre entreprise travaille que
leurs banques
et quand les banques vont être rendus au
bout de la marge de manoeuvre nous
allons nous a aimés avec elle offert des
garanties prêts qui vont pouvoir être
mises en place très très très rapidement
au même moment on permet aux entreprises
de meschers et semant québec directement
et ça va être plus long si a pas de
relation qui existe déjà on en offre les
2 mai mais pourquoi des prêts garantis
trg est pourquoi pas des subventions
carrément aux entreprises il ya le
gouvernement fédéral annoncée des
subventions salariales opn ne touche pas
que d'une chose je fasse le volet
important mais police le biais zee santé
publique qui évidemment ça va de soi
deuxièmement c'est le filet social est
important conseil m avec le fédéral avec
monsieur bulli quelques minutes mais
c'est le gros monsieur girard ont
regardé comment ce que le filet social
on va le bonifier si full bonifiés pour
s'assurer que les entreprises quand ils
ont été pillés les [ __ ] du personnel
qu'ils soient pris en charge que les
gens puissent de me manger voir le toit
et appelant vos entreprises pour
l'instant on parle de crise de
liquidités on parle de situation où il
ya une cause à effet avec le virus sont
importants et deuxièmement qu'il ya une
une possibilité de revenir à la
rentabilité et c'était avant dans ses
colonnes je pense qu'un prêt de
liquidité et la baule instrument qui
sera payée l'inversé deux ans trois ans
ou 5 ans on constate ici je pense est
préférable pour les troisièmes dans
l'économie
et 600 entreprises dites vous tantôt m
ont demandé de l'aide d'investissement
québec est ce que c'est des entreprises
en difficulté ça jusqu'à maintenant
ba a coûté l'élection du premier concédé
entreprises qui réclament que le virus
kobe 19 a causé des problèmes de
liquidité sérieux donc c'est ce qui
l'est c'est ce que les réclamants
évidemment de travail il faut faire
s'assurer que ces entreprises là
effectivement c'est relié à sow est très
important il faut s'assurer à votre
point que si la compagnie un trou de
dette de mettre plus de dette ne se
promène donc ça prend évidemment
l'assurance de notre part donc fait une
analyse bien sûr c'est tout à fait
normal ça prend combien de temps ça va
prendre combien tu as un entrepreneur
qui a besoin d'argent
elle va lui prendre combien d'heures
combien de jours est-ce qu'on quelques
100 jours ou en semaines pour avoir le
soutien des trois situations si on passe
par les banques
c'est beaucoup plus rapide que les
banques sont déjà en relation d'affaires
avec l'entreprise a déjà des lignes de
crédit en place on augmente la marge de
crédit et que nos garanties sont super
véloce peu soir à quelques jours maximum
si c'est un client déjà chez
investissement québec c'est plus rapide
aussi au nom des relations au bac avec
les autres
si c'est une point clients
d'investissement québec et leurs phares
du travail ça peut être une couple de
semaines est important que les
entreprises bien de voir assez
rapidement mais je pense que règle
générale les entreprises peuvent voir à
la vente quel vosges de ranger les kinés
ont pu réagir mais les gens qui nous
écoutent une petite entreprise de cinq
employés est ce qu'on le dise ce soir
est-ce que je suis une petite entreprise
qui a par exemple cinq employés que des
difficultés qui manquent de liquidités
là est ce qu on sait ce que ce programme
ce que vous avez annoncé aujourd'hui les
cibles
oui en fait ce qu'on ne dit aujourd'hui
c'est que cela cliquez au minimum on a
dit le minimum est de sonder près de
50000 dollars ok règle générale je pense
qu'on va couvrir beaucoup et beaucoup
d'entreprises
or donc qui a accès en fait à ça c est
ce que c'est les deux cent cinquante
mille pme du québec
techniquement oui je vais faire
attention je pense que c'est important
de parler beaucoup de l'hibernation par
exemple de proue de commerce
d'entreprises qui vont devoir fermer
pour quelques semaines dans ces colonnes
je pensais beaucoup de programmes en
place leur part des détaxes gare à
montréal madame plantes
c'est ça aujourd'hui on a des rapports
de l'épaule acompte provisionnel
on a des loyers qui peuvent être
retardés les bandes vont être très très
tolérante pour les re par le moratoire
de qualité alors je pense qu'en règle
générale les y est fort probable que ces
entreprises vont pouvoir surtout suffire
avec ces mesures leur part qu'on nous
dit la 2e ligne il faudra garder celles
qui ne peuvent pas juste bénéficier des
reports c'était super on va regarder ses
projets c'est quand même incroyable
monsieur fait ce que bones qu'on vit
présentement de voir aussi la forte
intervention de votre gouvernement du
gouvernement du canada des banques
centrales est ce que les gens vont se
retrouver à travers tous les soutiens
finalement qu'ils seront disponibles
vous avez vos points manche non
seulement cette union que je le fédéral
ya je pense le donne beaucoup de crédit
pour le programme pour polluer individus
je pense et ce qui est fondamentalement
important pour la santé et pour
l'économie moi j'ai répondu que trois
phases d'intervention
il ya des phases d'intervention mode
survie hibernation qu'on a présentement
pour oublier quand ça va repartir et pas
savoir à partir de quand même il faut
pas oublier que ça allait bien avant que
le virus arrivé le virus il va avoir une
finalité on regarde la chine qui reprend
ses activités au regard de celle du
soleil par exemple à la division reprend
dans le cycle économique
ils voient des besoins de fonds de
roulement il faut être là aussi pourrait
voir la fameuse rolex et des projets de
d'investissement qui ont été mis sur la
glace ces projets là je veux que soit
activée aussi alors il ya trois niveaux
d'intervention d'infos très parcimonieux
pour pas de lancer d'argent à droite
qu'à gauche ne faut être très très très
rigoureuse ronge argent public
allez vous aider le cirque du soleil
probablement je le sais je sur est un
très bon exemple où monsieur lamarre on
est en contact quotidien depuis début de
semaine de se passer aussi a mis à pied
ont 100 personnes sur 13 cents au bureau
chef de prix les bons gestes les
employés vont être sous
le filet social le fédéral et provincial
dans certains cas et nous regardons
maintenant comment on regarde le cirque
du soleil en mode survie parce qu'on
veut voir un mur avant de dire que pour
la fin avril les ports du spectacle en
chine d'autres tournées vont être animés
programme en mai ou en juin
alors faut faut être pour ses compagnes
au plus haut point 4 ça va revenir à
deux sets partout si profitable dans
tous vos mots clés peuvent lui doit
quelques semaines nord
nous on a un rôle temporaire à jouer je
pense qu'il faut jouer merci monsieur
fait bbc